it's in my mind very important that the
EU is in the forefront of the fight
against tax avoidance it is an issue
which is on the top of our agendas in
almost all of our countries and in the
eye of the media and the public as well
the directive as we hope to agree at the
latest Monday night sets out legally
binding rules to enable member states to
tackle a corporate tax avoidance profit
shifting in a coordinated way all of
this of course building on the work done
by the OECD EPS recommendations then on
the banking union but more work needs to
be done and we've outlined that work in
what we call a road map which was agreed
today by the Member States roadmap which
deals with further Risk Reduction so
dealing with the risks that remain in
our balance sheets the bank balance
sheets and at the same time enhancing
the cooperation within the banking Union
also by sharing risks the Commission
will come with a further proposals on
Risk Reduction before the end of the
year on total loss absorbing capacity
and on capital requirements regulation
and capital governments director on it
itself we are not yet there and further
work is necessary so we look for to work
forward closely with upcoming Slovak
presidency and European Parliament on
the issue on this issue for the months
ahead the Commission has a wide range of
proposals to counter the global threat
of terrorism from the European agenda on
security presented in our April last
year to the proposal to limit access to
automatic weapons last week detecting
and halting financing flows to terrorism
is a part of this effort the Commission
will make a proposal on the revised
anti-money laundering directive on 5th
July we are committed to making progress
on this file rapidly and look forward to
working with a upcoming slow presidency